this is another Fox News Alert moments
ago Alabama governor kiv signed one of
the strictest abortion bills in the
country into law correspondent Jonathan
Serrie reports on the firestorm ignited
on both sides of this debate one that
could very well lead all the way to the
US Supreme Court the
republican-controlled state Senate voted
25 to 6 to make it a Class A felony for
doctors to perform abortions in Alabama
unless the mother's life is in danger
the measure makes no exceptions for
cases involving rape or incest life is a
gift of our Creator and we must do
everything that we can to protect life
outrage from state and national
Democrats soon followed I apologize to
the women of Alabama for this arcade law
that we pass we need to lift up their
voices we need to lift up the voices of
women and families across America who
see their civil rights and human rights
being taken away from them Democratic
presidential candidate Kirsten
Gillibrand plans to speak tomorrow at a
women's rally in Georgia where
Republican Governor Brian Kemp signed a
similar bill last week the Georgia law
has sparked calls for a boycott by the
state's two billion dollar film industry
that supports nearly 1 million jobs
actress and activist Alyssa Milano
called for a national sex strike
tweeting until women have legal control
over their own bodies we just cannot
risk pregnancy join me by not having sex
until we get bodily autonomy back the
debate over Alabama's bill has been
fierce last week the gloves were off
when a shouting match on the Senate
floor delayed a vote the legislation
will likely face an immediate legal
challenge it's designed in every way to
do just that that's why we were trying
to keep it just as it was was to address
the issue that Roe versus Wade was
decided on which is that baby in the
womb a person supporters say they want
the case to be taken up by the US
Supreme Court as the makeup of the high
court becomes increasingly conservative
the chances of overturning roe v wade
become increasingly possible Brett
Jonathan thank you more on this with the
panel